c'est un phénomène qui est apparue il ya
quelques années de plus en plus de
français se tournent vers la crémation
selon un sondage ifop pour les pompes
funèbres générales
la demande est actuellement de 32% et
devrait atteindre 50% d'ici une dizaine
d'années explications avec un
professionnel du métier devant les
cavurnes du cimetière des gones à
versailles le cours des obsèques
crémation sont en moyenne sur la région
parisienne de 3500 euros et en
inhumation d'environ 4500 euros pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas encore de
concessions
funéraire dans un cimetière pour des
inhumations il faudra acquérir cette
concession faire un monument funéraire
donc ce qui va augmenter la facture
d'eau tant d'autres facteurs expliquent
cette hausse comme le manque de place
dans les cimetières en région parisienne
certaines personnes considèrent aussi
que la crémation est plus écologique que
l'inhumation une demande de plus en plus
difficiles à satisfaire
compte tenu du manque de crématorium la
france en compte aujourd'hui 144 pour
plus de 160000 crémations par an il faut
effectivement que la france s'équipant
crématorium nous sommes un petit peu en
retard au niveau de ses équipements
les yvelines compte un seul crématorium
situé aux mureaux la construction d'un
tel édifice est à l'initiative des
communes sur appel d'offres auprès des
professionnels des pompes funèbres
par ailleurs la loi oblige les communes
de plus de 2000 habitants à disposer
d'un site cinéraire